[Music]
what up peeps i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report
direct message yes i am back in studio
today april 8th 2021 17 years four
months
three weeks and six days since two weeks
to flatten the curve it's very good to
be with you guys we are doing an
ask me anything q a directly
from the reuben report community at
reubenport.locals.com we've got a
gajillion questions they're all over the
map
i'm going to get to as many as possible
as always don't forget to subscribe and
click that notification bell and as many
of you guys know i was in new york city
for a couple days
and well the greater new york area i was
only in new york city for one day i'll
get to that in one of the questions it's
a very very scary place
and you should run as far away from that
place as possible
i'll get to that in a little bit but i
did the debut
of the greg gutfeld show he moved from
just saturday nights
to five nights a week 11 p.m on fox news
where he's doing his panel show it's an
hour-long
situation uh they crushed it absolutely
crush it on
night one uh almost two million viewers
which is fantastic obviously for cable
news at that hour
and uh i think he's gonna take out i'm
saying it right now i think by the end
of the year his ratings will be better
than
all of the network hosts whoever you
know there's colbert and there's the guy
in blackface and the other guy and the
other one
and they're all pretty terrible i think
gutfeld is gonna is gonna knock it out
of the park i'm gonna try to get to new
york about once a month
to to do that okay before we get to
anything though
we're gonna do one story uh which is
about biden's executive action
on guns which he just announced and it's
sort of a perfect story because
i've been referencing this clip from the
debates
when kamala and him got into it about
executive actions on guns and i think
you're going to see
why poor joe has is just over his head
at the moment before we do that though
guys i want to talk to you about
hartford gold you know i spend a lot of
time talking about cancel culture
and how the left tries to silence people
and the issues that they don't want to
hear about
well here's something we can't cancel no
matter how hard we close our eyes
or plug our ears the biden
administration is spending excessively
while killing energy jobs and dragging
down or dragging out lockdowns this can
be catastrophic for the american dollar
which is why it's smart to invest in
things that are real with intrinsic
value
which is why i'm encouraging you guys to
invest in gold i recommend you speak to
my friends over at american hartford
gold they sell
physical gold and silver delivered right
to your door or inside your ira plus
they make it easy and with a a plus
rating from the better business bureau
and thousands
of satisfied clients i know you will
come to trust them too when you call
today they'll give you up to
one thousand five hundred dollars worth
of free silver
with your first order so now is a great
time to check them out call 866 219-9311
that's
text 866-219-9311 to six five five three
two
don't wait secure your financial future
with gold and now back to me
okay so you may have seen it already
it's breaking at the moment all hell's
breaking loose on the
on the twitter.com over there uh joe
biden
uh gave a little talk this morning read
off the prompter fairly well for old joe
uh basically doing an executive action
move on
guns which we kind of all saw coming now
i'm gonna play a clip we're gonna show
you a little bit
from the from the chat that he gave at
the
chat whatever the hell it is the oration
the speech
the pre-written thing that he gave at
the white house today we'll do that in
just a second
but over the last six months or so i
have many many times referenced this
very specific clip that we're going to
show you right now
where joe biden and kamala harris get
into it during one of the debates now
you may remember she did run for
president she got out very early and was
polling at zero and then became
the vice president it's quite
extraordinary um but biden tries to
defend the constitution
as kamala tries to trample it and i
think you'll see why we're playing this
right now
take a look you did bring up assault
weapons here and many of you on this
stage have talked about executive orders
senator harris you have said that you
would take executive action on guns
within
your first 100 days including banning
imports of ar-15 assault weapons that's
right
president obama after sandy hook more
than 23 executive actions and yet here
we all are today
in recent days former vice president
biden has said about executive orders
some really talented people
are seeking the nomination they said i'm
going to issue an executive order biden
saying there's no constitutional
authority
to issue that executive order when they
say i'm going to eliminate assault
weapons saying
you can't do it by executive order any
more than trump can do things
when he says he can do it by executive
order does the vice president have a
point there
some things you can many things you
can't let's let the senator answer
well i mean i would just say hey joe
instead of saying no we can't let's say
yes we can
let's be constitutional we've got to
come yes we can
man that clip almost sums up everything
you need to know
about this story going forward there is
old joe who actually seems sharper than
he seems right now
saying you cannot do everything on guns
via executive action right we have
separation
of powers okay you can't do it as long
as the constitution means something
i don't think they really believe in the
constitution at this point but i think
you get the point
but there's kamala harris saying with
her evil that evil cackling laugh and
she sounds a little bit
like a stoner at the end of the night
and joe
can't we say yes we can
so you see it that that's a real
fundamental difference
now joe unfortunately for joe is in the
wrong room
in the wrong year discussing the wrong
thing because i don't think anyone in
that audience nor his base
nor clearly the the woke progressives
they care about the constitution i don't
think they care so
what kamala's evil cackling
diatribe really is about is kind of
where the energy is which is it doesn't
matter what the constitution says we're
going to do what we want can't we just
say yes we can
it doesn't really matter because who's
going to stand up for the constitution
joe who at his best or at his peak
before
whatever's going on with him understood
that you can't do all those things
okay so i've referenced that clip many
times because i always thought
somehow it was going to bubble back into
into the present so now let's just show
you a short clip
of joe biden today
most people don't know you walk into a
store and you buy a gun you have a
background check
but you go to a gun show you can buy
whatever you want and no background
check
okay so that is a lie we'll get to the
specifics on that i'm going to actually
use facts and numbers in just a second
to show you why
that is a lie that there is a gun show
loophole
but it is not anything near what joe is
implying that you can just walk into a
gun show and get a gun
just not true we'll get to it in a
moment but let's just get a little bit
more
on the specifics of all this this is
from the daily wire president joe biden
announced on wednesday
evening the administration's new
far-left executive order aimed at
cracking down on the second amendment
and the hiring of a new director of the
bureau of alcohol tobacco and firearms
who comes from an anti-second amendment
group the bureau of alcohol tobacco and
firearms they're having a good time over
there
the hill went on to say the department
of justice will issue a series of
proposed
rules aimed at restricting the
proliferation of so-called ghost guns
encouraging states to adopt red flag
laws and tightening loopholes
around certain modified pistols
and we've got a quote from a senior
biden administration official when
speaking to reporters
the president will not wait for congress
to act before the administration takes
our own steps
solely within the administration's
authority and the second amendment
to save lives i mean that statement is
sort of
meaningless because you really can't and
and the thing is
you can't because of the separation of
powers and you can't use executive
actions to override
uh our constitutionally granted rights
that are guaranteed to us in the bill of
rights
except you can do it if no one stops it
and i think that's really
what the progressive movement is all
about it's like yes we have separation
of powers we have a bill of rights we
have a constitution we have laws
but let's just run through all those
things because who's going to stop us by
the way ghost guns
sort of interesting i had not heard of
ghost guns but it did remind me of this
there it is the uh the ectoplasma gun or
something like that
uh which of course you know ghostbusters
if you haven't seen the original
ghostbusters in a while if you want to
see the greatest
libertarian movie of all time who turns
out
spoiler alert who turns out to be the
bad guy in ghostbusters it's not
the ghosts it's that douchebag from the
epa who comes down there and he shuts
off the containment unit
which then releases the ghosts out there
so he's basically
aoc telling private business what they
can and can't do
and now let's explain a little bit about
the gun show
loophole because joe just said you heard
the quote he said that you can walk into
a gun show
and get a gun without a background check
well this is from thoughtco
the gun show loophole refers to the fact
that most states do not require
background checks for firearms sold or
traded
at gun shows by private individuals
federal law requires background
checks on guns sold by federally
licensed dealers
the atf now estimates that as many as 75
of the weapons sold at gun shows are
sold by licensed dealers okay so there
is a difference
i don't want to get too lost in my
minutia here but there is a fundamental
difference between
licensed dealers selling guns at gun
shows which
that's about 75 of the guns sold are
versus private people
with their usual roughly small
collection selling to other private
people
okay that is what this is about now we
can have a debate whether that should be
allowed
but what joe biden just said there i
would say that's what we would call a
gish gallop he just lied over it
right like he could have told the truth
there he could have said you know there
is this interesting loophole
where federally you can't do it if
you're a licensed uh
seller but you know if you're a private
collector selling to another private
collector
blah blah blah but of course he's not
going to do that and the media won't
won't acknowledge it right they're not
even going
to acknowledge it they're just going to
repeat what biden
is saying thus the lie just proliferates
and
and gets out there and of course that
reminded me you know as i did this with
my hands it really reminded me
of jordan peterson because as you guys
know i was on tour with jordan peterson
for about a year and a half
and he often would talk about alexander
solzhenitsyn
who was a political prisoner and
dissident in russia
he was also a philosopher and an author
and wrote the gulag archipelago
archipelago and many other uh things um
he won a nobel prize in literature
actually
but i found this quote it's been going
around twitter and i've been using it
all the time and i just think that maybe
you guys should know this quote too so
maybe even want to screenshot this
the quote is we know they are lying they
know they are lying
they know that we know they are lying we
know that they know
we know they are lying and still
they continue to lie i think that is a
sort of perfect summation
of kind of where we're at at the moment
whether it's 60 minutes
lying about ron desantis we showed you
that clip a couple days ago
or whether it's joe biden lying about
the gun show loophole and no background
checks
or or whether it's the washington post
lying about
donald trump's call with the attorney
general
or the secretary of state of georgia
whatever it is they lie
they know that we know we know that they
know that we know
it's this endless awful thing and we've
gotta
fight through it so uh hopefully we will
all right i wanna get to the
q a here we got a whole bunch of great
questions uh but real quick guys i want
to talk to you
about gaby insurance you know when it
comes to car and home insurance
don't we deserve better i think so i put
my policy to test and turn to gabby they
literally stand for get a better
insurance
getting better insurance with gabby
means a better price for the same
insurance coverage
who knew something like this even
existed they are the one true comparison
platform with real rates they give you
an apples to apples comparison
of your current coverage with over 40 of
the top insurance providers like
progressive nationwide and travelers
all in one place use your current
insurance information to get started and
in just minutes you'll be able to see
quotes
for the exact same coverage you
currently have and it's free to use
it's fast and easy and gabby can show
you if you've been overpaying when i did
it i discovered
great deals as well as new insurance
companies and was quickly able to
compare the top
five rates by seeing them listed in
order which made navigating through the
plan super easy
gabby customers saved 961 dollars per
year on
average they'll never sell your info so
no annoying spam or robo calls
put your policy to test like i did get a
better insurance with gabby it's totally
free to check out
and there's no obligation go to
gabby.com ruben that's g-a-b-i
dot com slash reuben g-a-b-i dot com
slash reuben and now back to me okay
i will try to be brief to get to as many
as possible
if it's possible we shall see zionists
says
will you be boycotting united airlines
delta airlines coca-cola and other
companies that go woke
what do you think all conservatives
should do in effect
uh well look i think everyone can vote
with the dollar right you can vote with
your vote
and you can vote with your dollar uh by
the way people there seems to be some
confusion
as to whether boycotting something is
cancel culture i mean if you
decide okay coca-cola or delta
or whatever it might be some giant
corporation is
is putting ideas out there that you
don't like that don't sort of jive with
your world view
if you boycott them if you choose not to
give them your money that is not cancel
culture cancel culture is when a mob
basically
cancel culture is when a mob usually of
amorphous anonymous people try to
destroy an individual and get them fired
the beauty of the free market is you can
decide right it's one of the few
things that we can do as individual
people you can decide where you want to
put your hard-earned dollars
so i have really been trying i'm really
really trying to spend more money at
local businesses and not give all the
money to amazon i'm not even saying that
amazon did anything specifically bad
i'm trying to do certain things like
that like coca-cola guess what guys like
you really shouldn't be drinking
coca-cola anyway now i'm probably gonna
get murdered like that's like the most
dangerous thing that you could say
there's something like can you get me
the
the numbers on this how many teaspoons
or tablespoons of sugar
are in a can of coke it's something like
21. like try to imagine
what that would be like this is not a
can of coke this is spin drift they
don't sponsor me but i do love the
flavor of spin drift
but in one of these what is this 12
ounces yeah 12 ounce can
39 grams of sugar in a 12 ounce can of
coke like you should not be having that
much coke and by the way if you get diet
coke
then you're getting aspartame and it's
like it's not a natural compound anyway
i want to get into all that but the
point is
the point is yes you should do the best
that you can so like
look if these airlines are gonna are
gonna you know say okay we're getting
out of atlanta or we're getting out of
georgia
because of this racist voting law which
isn't racist and is actually
much less racist than places like
colorado
where they're moving the all-star game
to or places like delaware where joe
biden is from
well then it's it's up to you so i think
that's the best that's the best thing
you can do
and and really alongside that i would
say parallel to that build
new things build new things that's what
i did with locals
it's working i hope it continues to work
and does that mean that ultimately
conservatives or
whatever this wide swath of non-woke
people are it's like do we have to build
our own
airlines and railroads and technology
companies and
all of those things it's quite possible
i think that actually might be the best
thing we can do
because the things that they build will
crumble they will crumble because
they're not going to hire the right
people
do you think that the riots this is ham
handed do you think that the riots will
cause more damage
if chauvin is found innocent or if he's
found guilty this is obviously the
police officer who's on trial right now
for killing george floyd in minneapolis
um well look if he's found
innocent or or even not guilty of some
of the charges
all hell's gonna break loose and and i
would suspect even if he's found guilty
on everything all hell will still break
loose like that's it's baked in
it's baked in that these people think
they can use violence so if he's found
innocent on anything if he gets off on
one of the charges
then pretty much we know violence coming
if he's found guilty on everything well
you would think that they have no excuse
for violence but they love
violence and the media loves propagating
that violence right the media loves
talking about that violence and blaming
other people for that violence
there's always an excuse if you believe
that political violence
is valid if you think that you can use
violence
for political ends then of course you
will always find a reason to do so
and the media will cheer them on and
there will be democratic leaders blaming
the evil racist patriarchy that is
america and everything else so violence
is coming
one way or another you know one of the
things i discussed this i was on
newsmax a couple weeks ago with harvard
law professor alan dershowitz
one of the things that he brought up is
that keith ellison who
is the attorney general uh who's really
i mean he's a
really really far left like out there
guy
he's the attorney general of minnesota
and he included third degree murder
charges
in the the case here third degree murder
charges usually are something like when
you shoot into a crowd
and just kill somebody so it's like he
probably won't be found guilty on third
degree murder charges so they
overcharged in a way
right it's not the third degree is worse
than first degree
but they overcharged they added extra
charges and it's it's sort of like well
maybe did ellison do that knowing he's
really not guilty of third degree murder
and google what third degree murder is
but he put the charge in there because
he kind of wants the violence i mean i
do think
it's a sad reality i honestly do think
the democrats and the media want the
violence
vin says what are your thoughts on
stephen crowder and his whole situation
his youtube channel
has been demonetized demonetized
indefinitely
yeah i've been tracking this a little
bit and talking to my guys at the blaze
about what's going on there
i mean look the sad truth is look i love
being on youtube
it is incredible that quite literally
millions of people have found me through
this
and i've become successful and get to do
what i want to do and build businesses
all through the pipes of youtube that is
all wonderful but you know any of us
that create anything but it's not just
if you create things if you if you
consume things on youtube and you think
you're okay
you're not these are giant companies
that can decide at any moment
to shut anyone down to demonetize anyone
to blacklist anyone to algorithmically
suppress
anyone all of those things i mean this
is exactly why i started locals.com and
i hope that you guys have already
created an account at locals
reubenreport.locals.com you can create a
free account to see
pretty much everything and then if you
want to interact with it you have to pay
a couple bucks i believe that
actually having a little skin in the
game does make things better uh as for
as for crowder look
i like crowder a lot i think he's a
funny guy i think that
he's he's fighting the fight on their
terms
is he a little over the top sometimes
does he do some stuff that is a little
tasteless sometimes
sure but the job of a comedian is to
find that line
and get as close to it as you can and
you know what occasionally you're gonna
it's gonna get a little messy you're
gonna trip over it
speaking of stand up by the way we just
booked it we'll make the full
announcement in a couple days
but i will be doing i think five
stand-up gigs in florida in june
uh coop says it seems like the movement
to remove cuomo from office is dying
down and now he's pushing vaccine
passports
taking away more freedoms of new yorkers
what mechanisms can we use to hold
elected officials accountable
when the press doesn't i mean this is a
tough one so first off
i agree with your premise there that it
does look like he's going to get away
with this it's gonna it looks like he is
gonna get away with
putting all of those elderly people back
in the nursing homes and if you didn't
see my interview with janice dean whose
in-laws both died
once they put those people back in i
highly recommend we put it up last week
janice is just wonderful she's fighting
and i suspect that if he was impeached
or had to step down that she would
actually run for governor i'm not
sort of putting words in her mouth i
think that maybe she would do it though
um but it does seem that as the states
are kind of opening up right now or as
the conversation has shifted
to vaccine passports it does seem like
he's gonna you know walk
scot-free on that uh there are more and
more
accusations of you know sexual
impropriety and harassment and that kind
of stuff
again when it comes to that kind of
stuff i don't believe you're guilty
until you're proven guilty that's not
the
the set of rules that they use they use
the believe all women
that's what he wanted people to believe
when it was not him being
accused right but i would say as far as
those things it's like it's got to be
proven you got you got to have some
evidence it's got to be proven etc etc
uh i think what he did in terms of the
nursing homes is far far worse than that
but it does sort of seem like he's going
to get away but as far as holding them
to account
i mean the best thing i suppose you can
do is make your voice heard it's like
the little micro thing that you can do
and
and in your circles tell your friends
and family hey you know this guy did do
this and if they don't see it
if they if they're blue pilled right
they're blue and on people and they only
watch cnn in the new york times and they
don't really know what's going on there
you go you know try to show them
maybe one of my videos try to show them
something from shapiro or prager or
glenn beck or that scary crowder guy
go you know there is another story here
that's really the best i mean i always
bring things down to the local and
individual level that's
that's the best way we can do it i got
one more ad for you guys and then we're
going to get to all the rest of the
questions
uh you know free email services like
gmail and yahoo aren't really free
you pay with your privacy and since
those companies have access to every
email you send and receive big tech can
sell your data
to the highest bidder have i talked
about this before from business plans to
medical records companies can sell your
personal data to target you with
intrusive ads and open you up to
identity theft and phishing attacks
that's why start mail wants to secure
your email and make you feel safe again
start mail keeps your email private
period every email is encrypted even if
the recipient doesn't use encryption
which means big tech can't read scan
analyze or sell your personal info
ever start mail also prevents government
agencies from spying on you like in
dragnet operations
with start mail deleted means deleted
when you delete an email it's gone
forever and start mail uses their own
servers not amazons which means they
can't be put out of business like parlor
start mail is also backed by the most
stringent privacy laws in the world you
get unlimited anonymous aliases
this feature protects your main email
address from spam and phishing attacks
so when you're giving your email to a
company but want to protect your
identity start mail can generate a
shareable alias email
so people can't sell your information
and they can be deleted any
time check out start mail guys uh by the
way you know we did three ads in this
one because i didn't do shows earlier in
the week i try to keep
them to two to be respectful of your
time so that's a little public
announcement for you
uconn says that do you think they will
make a marvel villain
based on you as they did jordan peterson
if so which would you want to be all
right so if you don't know what yukon is
referencing here
so captain america the comic book they
let tanisi
coats who's a awoke social justice
warrior apparently they let him
write the most recent uh issue
of uh the the captain america comic book
and he takes
god it's so it's so it's so like
cataclysmically stupid
it's just beyond information what's the
bad guy's name what's his name
uh red skull red skull he's got a red
skull they take
red skull who's like the main bad guy
kind of nazi guy
from the captain america comic books i
think he was in
uh some of the avengers end game and
that kind of thing as well um they take
him and they basically make him jordan
peterson and
you know he has 10 rules instead of 12
rules and all this stuff now jordan is
doing a spectacular job
on twitter right now where he's just
flipping this and like just making fun
of it in like the best possible sense
i just posted an image on twitter of me
and jordan on tour together
we swapped out jordan's head for uh for
red skull there
but in essence this is what they are
doing these comic books have gone woke
and you know you can't actually be for
america and somehow cleaning your room
and personal
is now what the bad guy wants i mean
it's so bananas it's ridiculous but your
question was
if they make a villain a marvel villain
based on me as they did jordan peterson
who would you want it to be i had to
think about this for a little bit um
and i think the answer is venom i think
it would be venom because if you saw the
venom movie or if you know anything
about the original comic books right out
of the
out of the screen right here you can't
quite see it but i've got spider-man 300
and a couple of my other comic books
right there i was a big i was a big
spider-man guy that was my main comic
book back in the day
but venom you know venom was this sort
of he was a decent guy there was the guy
then and what's venom's real name
the guy himself brock was it eddie brock
i think it might be eddie brock
google venom real name i think was eddie
brock this guy and he was just a regular
guy and then the symbiote
you know comes from the other planet
gets on him and he's constantly fighting
it so he's always walking around like
doing he's trying to do his thing
and the next thing you know venom's like
kill them all and then get them murder
everybody
and i sort of think that's a little bit
of what i have to deal with during the
day
like that's a little bit of what twitter
is like like i'm trying to give you guys
information in a decent
you know sensible manner and then
something happens and i'm like
destroy them all so i think it's a
little bit of something like that and
it's a constant
balance between being a sane person and
being taken over by the
evil alien symbiote i think you all
understand that yes i got it right his
name was eddie brock
okay uh oh by the way guys uh sign up i
start mail i skipped over something
there
you can sign up today and you'll get 50
off your first year go to startmail.com
ruben that's s-t-a-r-t mail.com
ruben for 50 off your first year start
mail.com
reuben sorry about that uh anya says how
can people become braver
i feel like i'm surrounded by a sea of
cowards man i mean this is this is like
the toughest one that there is
it really is um well first off you know
i did a prageru video that we released i
believe the same day that don't burn
this book came out i think it was april
28th of of last year and the whole
purpose of the five-minute video
is that there is a bravery deficit and i
really believe this and i think it's
become more and more obvious you know
when i wrote the book
ironically i wrote the book a year and a
half or so before the book actually came
out the publishing world is just super
slow
but i think the things that i was
talking about the defense of
liberalism in the face of this woke
onslaught and that
there's nobody coming to save us i think
that's probably really what you're
asking here anya like how can i become
braver
the only way you can do it is by
starting to speak up
it doesn't mean you have to walk into
you know your place of business wherever
you work and start screaming everything
or
email blasting everyone all your
thoughts are fighting with everybody on
facebook
but in your little way whatever that is
whether it's with your husband or wife
or kids
or siblings or friends or local
community if you can just
in that regard stand up a little bit
more
for what you think is right you know one
of the things that the woksters are
doing they yell real loud and they send
anonymous
you know twitter mobs and all of that
stuff but i really believe that they're
a paper tiger and if more people would
just stand up i don't think i am
somehow uniquely brave or even uniquely
special in any way for some reason
i went down this path and now i tell
people what i think and obviously people
find value in that
but i'm fairly certain that if more
people
stood up and then there was less value
in what i'm doing
and people stopped watching i'd be okay
it would mean we were winning
it would mean that the world was
restoring back to something decent and
good and that would be an absolute
pleasure
and i will retire i don't play golf but
maybe i would take it up
ross so just it's just just do it in
your own life i know it sounds cliche
almost
or or trite but like just whatever you
can do
whatever you can do occasionally you
know what
try it this way post post this clip
on your facebook page see what happens
and if people start yelling
well you're talking to reuben and he's a
right wing nut bag or he's a racist or
whatever well
is he racist point out to me where he
was racist
is he a right wing nut bag point out and
just try to have the conversation
they're they're preying on the fact
that they can cow you into silence and
the more that you acquiesce the more air
you give them
to take you out it's as simple as that
uh ross says how do you explain to an
average
joe that mainstream media isn't truthful
it's sort of an extension of that last
question i mean look we saw what
happened with 60 minutes this week
an absolute hatchet job but if you don't
then watch stuff that's say here on
youtube
or the clips on twitter you know the
clip that we played
a day or two ago was from daily caller
they did a great
job they took the 60 minutes clip and
then they took the full extended answer
that ron desantis gave but that's not
going to be seen on cnn that's not going
to be explained
in a in a think piece in the new york
times so it makes it very difficult
that's that whole war on truth
and reality war thing i'm always talking
about right it makes it harder and
harder because your friends are going
wait a minute i saw this thing on 60
minutes
and they said that ron desantis was pay
for play to get people vaccinated or
he's a bad man
and then you could say to them but
publix issued a statement saying that
that didn't happen and even one of the
democrats in florida is admitting that
that didn't happen and ronda sanchez
explained the whole thing and none of it
happened and there go but i saw it on 60
minutes
and so this is a huge that chasm
like that spot between what they're
telling us
what's true and then the space in
between man that is tough to get people
there
i would say just it's sort of my answer
from the previous one but you got to
keep posting clips of things
post short clips and by the way if your
friends
if your friends and family befriend you
or say mean things to you or whatever it
is because you posted something that you
thought was interesting or insightful or
maybe somewhat agreed with
maybe not even fully agreed with if if
that's their response to you
then i guarantee you you probably need
better friends and i also guarantee you
that you will get better friends
trust me i lost a lot of friends in the
in the scheme of these last couple years
right
a lot of people turned on me public
people turned on me private people
turned on me i've still got some stuff
that i'm that i'm working through with
some people but you will feel
better you will feel better by being
yourself like do you want to live on
your knees
forever like it really is that simple
like do you want to live on your knees
as the water is rising the water is
going to get you quicker you're going to
drown a little bit quicker or would you
dare
stand up on your own two feet and see
what happens so
keep pushing out as much truth as you
can i mean i guess that's a
very jordan peterson of me but that's it
lacey says if president
trump had proclaimed [ __ ] cancer
throughout his presidency do you think
everyone with trump derangement syndrome
would now have some weird
affection for cancer kind of yes there's
a huge amount of people who decided for
the course of basically five years the
four years of the presidency and
probably the year before and even to
some degree what's happened post
that all of their views are just
completely 180 opposite of whatever
trump
did so when trump had kid you know kids
in cages
which was an obama era thing in the
first place it was evil and it was
concentration camps and all of those
worst things that's aoc of course
and now that biden has it and they're
actually way more packed and it's
significantly worse now she's kind of
quiet about it and
no we're not so sure about those things
yeah so at some level it's like you take
the word you know like the worst
sort of thing out there cancer if trump
had well let's do it this way since
we're talking a lot about vaccines and
things of that nature
if trump had said three years ago we
found a vaccine for cancer
and if everybody uh you know gets
vaccinated
with this thing we're not gonna have
cancer anymore try to imagine what the
media would have said
let's assume it was true for a moment
that they actually cured cancer
under the trump administration and the
fda said we did it
orange men you know got got rid of a
little regulation we were able to do it
we solved cancer and then they said okay
so everybody can get vaccinated now
and actually you have to get vaccinated
because uh you know you could get cancer
in the future which is sort of what's
happening right now with covid right and
vaccines
um i am fairly certain that half the
media well probably
excuse me i thought i was going to
sneeze in the midst of that that was
kind of funny um
i'm fairly certain that most of the
media uh
would have said that trump's trying to
kill people and this hasn't been tested
enough and blah blah blah blah
sort of like a year ago right now when
trump was saying that we're going to
have a vaccine within a year and
everybody was saying he's evil and we
shouldn't have to
take his vaccine and even kamala harris
was like i don't trust his vaccine and
andrew cuomo implied that too
so yeah you need to know what you stand
for not just what you stand against and
i think unfortunately
so much of our politics is oh i don't
like that guy so i believe in this
but you got to have some principles that
stand the test of time uh candace is how
is new york
more or less crazy than l.a i'm glad you
asked this candace so as i said i was in
new york for a couple days for gut felt
and then i finally saw my folks which
was wonderful i haven't seen this whole
time i got to see my brother and
sister-in-law and the kids it was
fantastic i beat my 11 year old
nephew in nba 2k that's right i still
got some skills
it's very impressive i used the uh 90-91
trailblazers he used the like 89 lakers
and i won by four it was phenomenal
drexler had like 35 and
eight assists anywho uh new york city
itself
i'm trying not to be hyperbolic or
sarcastic or over the top here
it was legit kind of scary so you know
because the gut fell people took care of
me i was
staying with my brother then a car
picked me up dropped me off right in
midtown
at the fox uh fox news studios
and um you know it was probably about 5
30 or so so it was getting a little bit
dark
and now first off it really felt like a
ghost town there were very few people on
the streets
normally what would be happening at 5 30
or 6 o'clock
new york city midtown thousands and
thousands of people right the hustle the
bustle the cars honking people running
out into the street
jaywalking almost getting hit people
crashing into each other
people yelling music the guys selling
shawarma on the side all of that
stuff love it or hate it the whole
gestalt of new york city right
and by the way i lived in new york city
i think most of you probably know this
but i lived in new york for most of my
adult life for
about 18 years or so from a little
before 9 11 just until i moved to
to to la i love new york city absolutely
love new york city and
over the course of now over a hundred
years
there have been at times dozens of
family members of mine in new york city
we've got
one left i've got one cousin left on the
on the upper west
as far as i know she's still there
because people are fleeing my sister and
her
husband and kids got out of there during
lockdowns everyone's just getting out i
had another cousin who just left
anyway it felt very eerie because not
only was it not the hustle and bustle
and tons of people
but one thing this this may seem sort of
odd but one thing that i noticed that
pretty much
everybody that was walking around was
walking around solo
so you're used to seeing people in
groups people talking laughing but
everyone was walking solo and
everyone's got a mask also so everyone
looks kind of shady
there are barricades all over the place
police looking around like it just
it didn't it felt like a shell of itself
that's the best way i could describe it
it felt
kind of dystopian like what would a
dystopian city look like ironically
later that night me and my brother my
nephew watched i am legend
and if you haven't seen i am legend or
you haven't seen in a couple years you
know what i am legend is basically about
they try to cure cancer right it starts
with this doctor curing cancer and then
it turns out that that vaccine ends up
turning everybody into zombies
and then basically decimating new york
city and it becomes a ghost town
and i was like ah this is a little
little too on the money right now to be
watching although
it really is a great movie uh but yeah
new york city did not
did not feel right it did not feel right
and uh
you know regardless of your feelings
about mass and vaccines and everything
else
the the breakdown of just humans doing
things that we took for granted just a
year ago
is uh is really catastrophic and i think
we're going to be living with this stuff
for a long time
tyler says who would win in a fight a
surge of immigrant children
or aoc armed with three swords
interesting question an important
question who would win in a fight a
surge of
immigrant children or aoc armed with
three stories i assume immigrant
children
and she would have to just let them go
she would have to impale herself because
if they want to come in
you know we've caused all the problems
that's what aoc said it's our
imperialism
and climate change and all of the things
that we have done because we're very
very evil
here in the united states and despite
our evilness everyone still wants to
come here but she would have to harry
carry herself she'd have to impale
herself
on her own sword her all three swords
and the children would have to just
waltz in that that would be it it would
be as simple as that really uh all right
guys we got to a bunch
uh oh check out parts one and two of my
interview with samuel
rodriguez this is a really interesting
interview that i did so he
is a pastor at a church here in
california who also has worked
with i believe three administrations i
believe he worked with the george w bush
administration
worked with the obama administration
worked on the trump administration
related to immigration he had some
really really interesting things to say
particularly
on how donald trump was desperately
desperately trying to make a deal
on immigration on a pathway to
citizenship and everything else
and how the democrats just basically
were like hey we're just not going to
give him a win even though he's given us
everything we want
really really interesting interview we
also talk obviously a lot about
a lot about faith and uh you know just
the struggles it's a little bit like the
the panel we did last friday uh on faith
that i did with bishop baron and rabbi
wolfie just about how people
are looking for answers right now and
the more that truth seems to be
destroyed
by by rampant secularism and our our
media that's just evil at this point
that people are looking
for er to other places for truth and
they're finding it actually maybe in
some of that
old time tested stuff so parts one of
one and two with samuel rodriguez are up
on the youtube and of course you can
watch the full thing
absolutely ad-free at
rubinreport.locals.com i have roughly 5
000 meetings
today and a few other tv hits and other
things of that nature so i got a busy
day ahead of me i hope you enjoyed the
show
uh and next time if you want to play
along get your questions in
report.locals.com thanks everybody have
a great day
you